you posted a dance move recently that I
wanted to ask you about because I was
intrigued by this you can actually it
appears like you have like a superpower
and I wanted to ask you about it let's
just take a look at this dance moving
then you can describe what's happening
here it's what it's just about the
gluteus maximus isolation isolating just
gotta isolate each butt cheek and it's
just it's not as I mean it's not I wish
I could do you could do whatever you
want to do I'm doing it all right let's
do it
it's just a little wait wait can you
teach corner do this
[Applause]
you there
okay cuz he's just gonna do a little
booty isolation it's gonna go one cheek
other cheek I can't I have no ass what
to speak up I have nothing here there's
nothing here I have no nerve endings
down here I have nothing
what about one big just both cheeks
nothing's happening for effort that's
horrible no I can't do that there's
nothing there's nothing yes
[Applause]
pretty high fiving my own humiliation
it's just the worst but I honestly don't
understand how you do that that's
amazing you're just isolating you I
learned this from a lot of do this I've
turned this on the show a lot I do that
all the time pretty good I just keep on
putting the eyebrows up yeah yeah and
isn't that cool yeah yeah no that's
literally all I've got right there
you're funny hilarious I got this
you